on the mound
is chris paddock getting ready for his
third start and the 24 year old he's got
to be fired up he's got to stay within
himself there you see this season's
numbers only two starts with the 1-0
record the very nice erie 1.64 we're set
jack peterson left-handed batter all
those lead-off home runs to face chris
paddock first pitch of the game paddock
to peterson a swing and a fly ball
into center field and deep and gone on
the first pitch of the game
jack peterson goes the other way his
first home run of the year
one pitch one-nothing dodger he sees an
awful lot of change-ups but he sees the
heater he says thou shall not pass
gonna find his bearings here in the
first inning as max muncie stands in one
two pitch and a swing and a miss good
way to come back strikes out max muncie
for the first out one now brings up
justin turner
swing and a miss and back-to-back
strikeouts for padding nicely done
as walkability makes his second start he
cruised through a few innings
on tuesday in houston but then ran into
some trouble in the fourth here's trent
grisham fly ball oh my goodness
rushed
to deep ratfield and long gone for trent
grisham
under the category i believe it's called
no doubt about it
chuck
run at the top of the first trent
grisham answers for the padres in the
bottom of the first and we're tied at
one cut fastball right down the middle
everything is in sync
and he knew it just like the other ones
he has hit up to this point and i tell
you what that ball was crushed
[Applause]
that's a breaking ball what a pick by
turner at third gunning to first but off
the bag and fam with lord
turner did a great job just to get his
glove on it
as it stands right now an infield hit
although they are going to challenge he
might be out justin turner might have
pulled off a five to three put out see
what the call is out
that is an awesome play by turner and
baby boat tied at one in the third is
the 3-0 come saw machado with a green
light flips it off the end of the bat
short right field not an easy play
beatty with a juggle and a catch
oh alright skips a beat there but
beatty's able to grab it and that
actually would save a run because with
two out
grisham was off and running
two outs and will myers took on to the
warning track in left center field
myers sends this one to deep right field
peterson going back at the wall that
ball is gone well myers with a solo home
run his third of the year and with one
swing of the bat the padres take it to
one lead
opposite field shot for will myers
oh that sounded good you know he just
missed earlier in the game playing out
the deep center field there's no doubt
about that one he gets will smith to the
plate with a tying run in third and the
go ahead run it first
gone on a 2-1 pitch will smith
lifts one to right center field grisham
on the move won't get there
that's in the gap extra bases for smith
to score seeger
beatty headed for the plate relay is
late and the dodgers have taken the lead
will smith with a two-run double that
makes it 3-2 in the fifth 3-2 los
angeles out hitting the boys 5-2 padre
two hits are both left the wall yard
high fly ball deep right field i thought
he got it all off the bat car rushed
right field tatis
just like just opposite field again like
in san francisco
they signed him is like 165 pounds look
at him look at him now big fella
big fella
you know those home runs that tie the
ball game and bring you back from
being down and get a lead
they're big aren't they really big
tied to three
and max muncie
he's at the plate
and sends one down the first base line
kronerworth gets it and wins the race to
the bag
but a play by jake cronenworth laying it
out at the line to make that grab
and then quickly scampers to the bag for
out number one that's machado the second
one away
here's cronenworth
well he's done it defensively all night
i guess it's time for jake to do
something dramatic at the back this is
lying to the left field it's gonna get
on down it did hoffy picked it up he's
gonna bring him on home up and throwing
in left field by pollard and this ball
game is a lead again for the san diego
padres they haven't been staying down
long for three san diego and the padres
with two down half runners at the
corners
line to left field for hedges and that's
it for a base hit from third comes
cronenworth and the padres take a 5-3
lead austin hedges picks up his first
hit of the year and it's a big one
the padres have a 5-3 lead with last
year's mlb saves leader on the mount at
the plate is last year's national league
mvp cody bellinger bellinger turns on
this ball and lifts it in the air to
right field forget about it a lead off
home run for cody bellinger
so he does in fact get kirby yates whose
struggles continue
and they're within
one pollock strikes out kirby yates has
his first out of the ninth inning
corey seeger coming up
zigger with his swing and a miss strikes
out kirby yates with back-to-back
strikeouts two down
two down in the ninth and chris taylor
standing in
he struck him on the padres win
kirby yates picks up his first save as
the padres hold on and win it five to
four